-Our first guest hosts the Emmy-
and Peabody Award-winning show
"Last Week Tonight,"
which airs Sundays on HBO
and streams on MAX.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
John Oliver, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yes.
You know, it was a --
it was a bad time.
The strike was a bad time.
-Yeah, yeah. Really bad.
-We got to spend some time
together.
-Let's throw - - I know cursing
is --
-Encouraged.
-Oh, sure.
Let's call it a [bleep] bad time
because otherwise,
what are intensifiers for?
-Yeah.
-Yes. Very bad.
-And, you know, we did
spend some time together
during the strike.
That was nice.
But we were talking
about a lot of people
just assume when you're not
working that is a positive.
-Yeah, they sure do assume
that, don't they?
-Yeah.
-They assume that
almost every day, and they
assume that reminding you
of that might be a pleasant
thing for you to hear.
Yeah. It was nonstop.
People would say,
"Well, at least
you're getting some time off.
It must feel like a vacation."
And I most of the time
did not respond to that.
And when I did,
I was not as gracious
as I might otherwise have been.
I was on an elevator
with my wife,
and someone got off saying,
"Yeah, well, at least
you're getting a nice vacation.
That must be nice."
And I was following
them off to say,
"You're [bleep] wrong
about that,"
until my wife pulled me back,
and said, it's not our floor.
I know it's not our floor.
But that's -- that's not
appreciating the difficulty
of the situation that
I'm in right now.
-Right before the strike,
you were here,
and it was lovely
to have you here,
and your parents
were in the audience.
-Yes, that's true.
-Although you stressed to us --
-I did.
-Don't mention it and don't cut
to them.
-That's right.
Your producers asked, would they
like a camera on them?
And I had to say,
I cannot overstate enough
just how little they want
a camera on them right here.
It would be the meanest thing
I could possibly do to them.
And I've not been
a perfect child.
But yeah, they really did.
They were so excited
to be here, though,
and the thing they said
afterwards was it was really,
really fun to go
and watch a real TV show.
And they had been, Seth,
at my show the previous night.
Gets one step worse because I
went, "Oh, I think I understand
what you mean,"
because, you know,
it's like it's -- "30 Rock"
is kind of a really
exciting place to be.
So I think I see it.
And they said, "Well,
could we go and see Colbert
next time that we're here?"
And I said, "Why?"
And they said,
"Because it would be nice
to see a real guest."
[ Laughter ]
Wow. Yeah.
So if there's any sense
of why I'm like this,
there's a little snapshot.
That's why my feet are --
-You kind of feel like --
there should be
a Huffington Post article
that's like, "John Oliver's
parents destroy John Oliver."
-Eviscerate their own boy.
-A very well structured
two-part burn on you.
-Yeah. That's right. Yeah.
-Also that thing of --
I mean, by the way,
don't blame us for asking like,
do you want a camera
on your parents?
Because, you know, of course,
when my parents come,
they actually bring a camera,
just in case
something's wrong with ours.
-Your dad is permanently live
streaming himself,
just so you've got two cameras,
so you can edit around him.
[ Laughter ]
-Now we also talked, you know,
people like us, hosts,
we get asked -- it makes
natural sense to people,
"Oh, you should host
my charity event."
-Oh, yeah.
-And you, over the years,
have just eliminated
multiple charities
where you're suitable for.
-Yeah, I talk a lot
of [bleep].
-Yeah.
-So helpfully for me that --
Yeah, I think I --
-It's, like, narrowed the field.
-Exactly. There's not many --
and so there's not many
that I can do
or that I'm welcome at now.
-But then you mentioned the one
thing.
-I mentioned last time.
"Sesame Street's" the greatest.
I love --
-Of course, the best.
-Obviously, I love them
in general so much.
I love the idea of them getting
as much money as they can.
So every year,
I do the "Sesame Street" gala.
So I mentioned it here
because it's so fun,
and I thought
this would be nice, too,
and I knew it was coming up.
I was then booed at that gala.
And I want you to think
about how hard it is
to make that happen.
The theme of the evening
was kindness.
[ Laughter ]
That's not easy to do.
Just to explain what happened --
So obviously, the whole point is
raise as much money as they can.
They got a big sponsor.
They had Bank of America
were going to be their sponsor,
and I think they got
Bank of America
by making up this nonsense award
they were going to give
to one of the executives.
I was going to go on after her.
And she walked on and she said,
"I've been thinking about
how appropriate it is
that Bank of America and "Sesame
Street" have teamed up tonight,
because we are two organizations
built on kindness."
And I was standing
at the side of the stage.
I remember thinking,
"Hm.
I'm going to let that go,
because no one needs me
to create a scene."
Alright now, you know,
she's out.
All the characters
are out there with her.
The whole point
is that we raise money.
No one needs an incident
just because she said something
that I personally find
a little odd to say,
so I can let that go.
I will choose to let that go.
I'm going to make
the better choice right now.
Then she said it three more
times in the next five minutes,
and I snapped and I walked out
and said,
"It's been odd to hear talk of
kindness from Bank of America,
an institution that had
the highest foreclosure rates
over the last ten years."
Boos bouncing --
Oh, that's the opposite
of the reaction in that room.
And the worst thing, the thing
that has imprinted itself
on my memory, is all I remember
is Bert looking up at me
with such disappointment
in his eyes.
Just, "Why are you like this?
You're behaving erratically,
and I live with Ernie."
It wasn't great, so I would
like to do it again.
"Sesame Street," have me back.
I'll be a good boy this time.
-Yeah.
They can trust you on that.
-Oh, definitely.
[ Laughter ]
Just have McKinsey be a sponsor.
They'll be fine.
-I've got a lot more
to ask you.
We'll be right back with more
from John Oliver.